we've been doing data collection with
these vehicles for about a year now we
have 45 vehicles on the road there's 22
in the US 23 in Western Europe we'll be
adding another 150 vehicles to the fleet
in 2013 we have two different types of
camera systems on the car the first are
high precision cameras that's the lower
set of cameras that you see around you
see them pointing at the buildings and
in off to the sides and also in front of
us it's capturing all of the sign data
all of the text information that you're
seeing on buildings all the addressing
the cameras on top are more panoramic
imagery therefore creating beautiful
pictures now what really makes these
vehicles unique is that sensor that's
rotating there in the middle and that's
what allows us to create the 3d nature
of the maps that is a laser sensor there
are 64 lasers in that device and as it
rotates around its collecting 1.3
million points of data every second now
these points of data each have an XY and
Z coordinate associated with and which
means we can measure the distance
between any two points on there that
means we can tell you what the width of
this road is what the height of the
curve is we can measure all of these
buildings and create an exact 3d digital
representation then of this real world
if you combine that point cloud of data
which doesn't have any color associated
with it with the colors coming off the
panoramic camera imagery now all of a
sudden we can actually create a digital
representation that looks like the world
that we see here